hello I'm Stephanie Flanders on today's
episode I'll be speaking with the
International Monetary Fund's chief
economist Gita Gopinath the IMF has just
produced its latest forecast for the
global economy and they're pretty bleak
it's expecting the global economy to
shrink by 3 percent this year that would
be the steepest global reduction since
the Great Depression certainly worse
than anything that happened in the
global financial crisis
[Music]
Geza Gopinath looking at these forecasts
I noticed that you have your baseline
scenario for the global economy and then
everything else all the alternatives are
worse what's driving the IMS forecast
that we are heading for this economic
contraction and why do you think that
all the alternative scenarios could be
even worse so we you know our baseline
assume is that the pandemic and the
containment measures will peak in the
second quarter for most countries in the
world and then come off gradually in the
second half but clearly that's not a
given and talking to a meteorologist and
public health officials there's
certainly no certainty that will happen
now there are some countries where you
are seeing containment measures working
and there is you know a flattening of
the curve and the number of new cases
are coming down but it's still too early
to say which is why we look into these
other scenarios where the containment
measures need to go into the second half
of this year and even into 2021 and if
that happens then it will be you know
doubling of the downturn which is from
3% a negative 3% to negative six percent
in 2020 and almost no recovery then in
2021
so it would be much much worse does the
IMF need new tools to deal with this
crisis help emerging market economies
get the support they need or is it just
about scaling up what you already have
at the IMF we've had close to 100
countries come to us for financing needs
at least just in the last in the last
how long well in the last four weeks I
mean a total of about a hundred so it's
a very large number coming in a very
short I don't think we've had 100
countries come to us before so this is
unprecedented and then of course the
speed-up itch is even more unprecedented
globally we've seen governments and
central banks do all they can very
quickly to limit the damage done by the
shutdown of the economy to defeat the
virus despite all that extraordinary
effort how worried are you about the
permanent damage to the economy and a
society that might
come from this crisis I think there is a
substantial risk in that you know this
is a crisis that's help and that's
affecting small and medium enterprises
along with some of the big ones and
getting to them is much harder there is
a lot to be concerned about here I mean
another thing I would like to want to
flag is then while in the past when
there's been a crises and you have all
the stimulus in the system it is a
stimulus which is you want people to go
out and spend you want firms to invest
now but that's not what the other side
of this crisis is which is the health
crises and so but at the same time all
of this stimulus is in the system we
want people to stay at home and not
exactly go out and spend so it's a very
different transmission channel this time
round the hope is that you will keep
people with sufficient income so that
they can meet their needs that firms and
businesses can stay afloat and once we
get past this period of lock down that
that things would recover much faster
but I mean the economic landscape
look very different once we come out of
this lock down and I think there's
tremendous uncertainty you think of
another chief economist of the IMF thank
you very much
thank you Stephanie